early morning military drills by these
new female recruits they're among the
first 1300 women to voluntary enlist in
Colombia's Army in more than two decades
the physical exercises are grueling and
the hours long that they say they're up
for the challenge and happy to be able
to serve
it's a tremendous opportunity we have
the same abilities as men and the
physical requirements are the same we
expect no preferential treatment for
being women it fills me with pride that
we are eligible for service once again
says she always wanted to be a soldier
but lacked the money to pay for a
military academy she hopes this will be
a gateway to achieve it
pursuing a professional career is too
expensive for many but now we have an
opportunity to be here and do what we
always wanted wear the uniform and serve
our country
's training here before being assigned
to a base across the country earning a
monthly stipend of about eighty dollars
says she entered the program to help her
mother and siblings and understands the
dangers of serving in a country still
plagued by Rebel groups and Drug mafias
the risks are high but that's why we
have a chain of command and we are being
trained for whatever we will have to
face in the future
women make up just one percent of the
country's 240 000 soldiers and Colombia
still relies on drafting 50 000 men
every year into compulsory military
service
the overwhelming majority of them come
from poor families well wealthier
Colombians pay to avoid it something the
government is planning to change
president Gustavo Petra is trying to
eliminate compulsory military service
allowing young recruits to choose Social
Services instead while increasing the
number of both professional and
volunteers including women
increasing the number of women in the
Army changes the culture of the
institution and the idea is to rely on
the more and different activities
security defense where they can
contribute a lot Colombia is planning to
enlist at least 5 000 women in 2023
alone strengthening their role and
working to diversify an evolving Force
Alessandra Al Jazeera Bogota